[Musique]
au sommaire de ce nouveau numéro de
barre 78 l'invité elle a été l'une des
premières grandes championnes françaises
karine espinasse beauval et découvertes
le golf des yvelines
retour aussi sur l' open tv 78 qui s'est
déroulée le 22 septembre dernier et
enfin matériel une nouvelle application
de caddie virtuel lots birdie
[Musique]
elle a été une des meilleures joueuses
du circuit européen du circuit américain
et des circuits asiatiques
elle est devenue depuis directrice de
golf c'est l'invité de par sedan 1 18
karine espinasse beauval et karina
spin-off beauvallet bonjour vous êtes
depuis devant la directrice des yvelines
mais il ya eu une vie avant notamment
ils ne sont plus comme sur le parcours
européen sur le projet tic sol américain
mais le golf est entré comment dans
votre vie j'ai démarré très petit
très jeune à 7 ans mes parents voilà
mais il n'y avait pas de date ayant été
dans la famille on a bien démarré
ensemble
holy chantilly c'est mon premier club
j'ai fait pas mal de sport et plus le
golf naturellement à prier me coupe pas
dans ma vie et je suis entre une équipe
de france amateur à l'âge de 13 ans oui
vous avez su très vite que j'ai été
longtemps entre tennis et le golf ray et
chacun des professeurs essayé de me
retenir c'est le cas de leur spécialité
et puis naturellement voilà c'était
monsieur plus moi qui ai demandé à
rester dans le milieu du golf et
franchement je ne regrette pas et là
vous avez une carrière amateur très
court 10 titres et vous décider comment
devenir pro ça s'est fait finalement
très peu de temps puisque une fois que
j'ai terminé numéro un européen des
françaises amateurs à l'époque les mains
lors du mérite amateurs en france qui ne
laisse pas forcément aujourd'hui en tout
cas le système de comptage est plus le
même
enfin 85 voilà j'avais une super année
ma meilleure année en tant qu'amateur et
je me suis dit c'est 4 5 mois pour
réfléchir jamais été approché par à
l'époque gilles ainsi entre autres qui
avaient monté une structure de
management sportif fidh avait souhaité
que je vienne le rejoindre et jeudi un
coup tu attends un peu sait pas trop ce
que je vais faire voulais faire des
études un peu plus poussé puis
finalement je partis trois quatre mois
un peu en hibernation
non notre prospection de manor voilà ce
que sait faire de ma vie et je me suis
dit allez on se lance
voilà on y va à l'époque le
golf féminin s'était alors aujourd'hui
un circuit qui est très fort c'était
aussi fort que ça veut dire c'est
paradoxal c'était beaucoup plus fort
qu'aujourd'hui quand je suis passé pro
86 d'abord la première française à le
faire et sur le calendrier il y avait
entre 27 et bat a fait preuve sur
circuit européen aujourd'hui les arrive
difficilement à 10 la conjoncture
étaient complètement différentes
il y avait l'explosion du golfe dans les
années 90 moi je suis arrivé en plein
dans les périodes là j'ai pu bénéficier
de deux de l'image des de l'intérêt des
médias et simon comme vous dites j'ai
réussi à véd'a alors celle-ci cup une
épreuve professionnelle française en
france jusqu'à ce que la loi evin
l'interdisent de le faire on est parti
ce parti en allemagne
mais c'est vrai que pendant les trois
premières années de ma carrière de pro
j'ai blessé beaucoup de lumière sur
moi-même et sur le golf féminin
voilà ça c'est par rapport à ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui ça peut décevoir de
voir ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
ah ouais bah c'est ya un problème un
problème au niveau du circuit
j'en connais un petit peu l'historique
et les filles méritent beaucoup plus que
ce qu'elles ont aujourd'hui
alors cette can je disais il ya une
circuit européen mais vous êtes aussi
partie sociale mais américain alors ça q
asiatique helvétique surtout associative
pour cette suite en circuit asiatique
d'hiver là que nous a permis de bob
avoir autre chose de voir d'autres
parcours que notre ambiance une autre
vue et d'autres mentalités à notre
esprit très enrichissant sacré américain
non j'ai j'ai osé
enfin j'ai réfléchi mais j'ai mon cv et
mais les amis et la famille à l'époque
moment me manquait était pour moi très
important et j'ai pas osé passer le
passé le cap
voilà mais les souvenirs que vous avez
de cette période c'est que ce circuit
que les bourses sont que des bons
souvenirs
un peu de nostalgie de temps en temps
parce qu'on est restés très amis avec
beaucoup de brio de joe de l'époque qui
sont maintenant comme moi des jeunes
seniors qui sont reconvertis dans
d'autres choses que ma conversion actuel
avec qui nous restons en contact et on
aime beaucoup ont parlé entre nous et
pour moi cette peur de ma vie qui fait
entre 15 et 20 ans de ma vie
finalement de haut niveau sur l'écho du
bonheur c'est que des bons souvenirs
il ya eu des open bars comme n'importe
quel jeune carrière est sillonnée de
différents moments mais pas mort s'il ya
un bilan à faire pour moi c'est que du
positif et je regarde ça avec beaucoup
de beaucoup d'affection c'est un devis
pour moi est importante et elle est à
l'astral à quoi quand est-ce qu'elle a
vous décidez de bad arrêter cette
campagne à un moment on sent peut-être
un peu moins en moins on a envie de
faire autre chose
alors c'est fait un arrêt forcé dans le
sens où j'ai un accident de voiture en
95 québec et qui m'a obligé à m'arrêter
pendant plus d'un an
est ce que j'ai la main fracturée à
douze endroits différents la main a été
broyée alors pour un golfeur c'est
compliqué j'ai tenté de revenir sur
circuit avec les enfants médical mais
c'est très compliqué parce que d'une
part physiquement je n'étais pas revenu
à 100% et psychologiquement le fait
d'arrêter comme ça pendant plus d'un an
on sort complètement du du cercle il
pendant ce temps là les autres
progressent si vous vous essayer de
récupérer
et puis on sait très bien remonté la vie
j'ai voulu parler vous n'avez pas avoir
de regrets donc j'ai tenté j'ai essayé
ça n'a pas fonctionné et je me suis dit
je passais à autre chose voilà donc j'ai
arrêté mon genre est officiellement
j'ai rencontré mon mari ben tout s'est
enchaîné derrière on a une autre enfant
tout finisse et puis et puis voilà on
est passé aux diablerets c'est la
musique et la vie en a décidé au petit
messi
voilà vous restez quand même dans le
domaine du golf dans le main event
manciet ben oui alors c'est vrai que
quand j'ai arrêté ma carrière je me suis
dit j'ai quand même rester dans le monde
du golf
ce monde je peux pas m'en défaire et
c'est à nouveau la vie qui vous amène
les opportunités qui voilà donc c'est
lionel provost l'ancien patron et
propriétaire de promo golfe qui m'a
voilà qui me réaliser le grand acteur du
monde français avec la fédération la pjf
et autres promoteurs de grandes épreuves
professionnelles et iliad elle m'a dit
voilà bien via travailler pour moi ont
balancé un département féminin événement
scène et je me suis retrouvé à m'occuper
du madame figaro
l'open de france féminin la france
doivent ils enfin deux gros événements
où j'étais chef de projet et directeur
de tournoi voilà ça ça a duré trois ans
et c'est trois années fantastiques et là
au fond moi mais la finalité après tout
ça c'est d'un jour 2 avec tout ce que
j'ai pu apprendre dans le monde du golf
par différents biais c'est pouvoir la
mener et de pouvoir gérer un jour un
golf mais je savais pas quand est prévu
et je suis arrivé ici à nouveau par
hasard comme beaucoup de penseurs des
yvelines
en tant qu'enseignante bac lorsque
l'ancien directeur chercher un
enseignant plus particulièrement pour
gérer les entraînements des équipes
l'entraînement des dames les cours
particuliers
c'était nécessaire pour lui de le
remettre un petit peu en mouvement je
suis arrivé ici
et puis au bout d'un an il m'annonce ce
que il part à la retraite et à ça fait
tilt je me suis dit voilà l'occasion se
présente
ma candidature a été retenue et je me
suis lancée voilà en 2009 avec les rênes
du boeuf
ouais mon premier poste et vous êtes
resté c'est toujours là toujours là
[Rires]
c'est quoi en direct le boulevard
directeur de golf parce que nous avons
tout à l'heure il y avait une
compétition c'est beau des prix vous
animiez tout ça il ya demandons qu'ils
allaient la réception des gens des
membres et puis il ya aussi gérer pas
complexe c'est très varié c'est à dire
que un directeur ou directrice de wolf
elle et elle est dans la même journée
elle peut passer dans cinq six
différents métiers dans la même journée
voilà et samson rencontre véritablement
parce que notre fonction été tuées
multiples et c'est une fonction qui est
méconnu les gens qui savent très bien ce
que c'est on s'égare directeur son
boulot on discute il parle avec les
mains parce que c'est que du rp alors
que c'est du rpi il ya la gestion de la
compta du commercial
il ya du rin keeping il ya les achats
les ratios restaurant il ya la gestion
des personnels à l'achat c'est un gros
gros compartiment où il faut être à
l'écouté qu'on a une peau
moi je suis gestionnaire d'une peine
légère 25 personnes à l'année sur des
secteurs et des services complètement
différents mais qui doivent marcher et
travailler ensemble c'est pas c'est pas
au départ toujours évident surtout que
moi en tant que joueur professionnel
j'étais très égocentrique quand on est
joueur professionnel dans un gris
j'entends je passe moi c'est d'abord
tous gravitent autour d'eux est le
centre d'intérêt de 7 de cette équipe là
c'est l'inversé partage et surtout
échanger partager donner vous cache pas
que la première année était un peu un
peu à tâtons
ça y est le fait d'avoir été jeu ce
professionnel avancé nier le fait d'être
du monde du golf
c'est un plus pour un directeur alors il
ya les deux je ne veux pas le faire de
généralités je dirais que c'est un plus
pour certaines choses toute la partie
parcours sensibilité les pétitions et
puis quelque part j'ai certaine
légitimité
c'est pas me raconter la baisse mais
quand j'ai un client qui vient me voir
en me disant patati et patata c'est à ça
et ça j'ai écouté voilà pas moi voilà
raconte tout ce que vous voulez sur
plein de sujets mais là selon moi au 15
mars à calmer un peu les esprits
après sur le reste et de l'apprentissage
aussi l'aléa des directeurs qui sont
issus du monde de la restauration du
tourisme d'autres qui viennent d'autres
horizons à un bon joueur une bonne
joueuse n'est pas forcément un bon on va
dire que ça aide c'est un plus un plus
quand même parce qu'ils la sensibilité
ya une connaissance du monde du golf que
l'on à quelqu'un qui est parachuté un
peu dans ce domaine là il faut un
certain nombre d'années pour la dans
l'apprentissage on peut pas faire une
généralité
voilà plus mais ça aide pour moi c'est
un peu quand même pour vous ça vous j'ai
vu quelque part on m'aurait combien ce
que vous vouliez souvent
au moins trois fois par an c'est quand
tout va bien c'est vrai pas puisque ça
alors c'est toujours pareil mais
directement on est je pense que le fait
d'être vraiment rester dans le monde du
golf
moi j'habite sur le gauche je parle
beaucoup de la journée
c'est vrai qu'il ya un moment où il ya
un trop plein émoi le fait d'avoir joué
énormément pendant de nombreuses années
à haut niveau
quelque part je dis pas qu'il ya un
rejet on n'est pas loin
ce projet je les passais donc là
aujourd'hui voilà les l'équipe dame m'a
relancé pour faire partie de l'équipe
seniors dames en troisième division je
pars tu joues et arras la trois semaines
avec elle j'ai pris beaucoup de plaisir
mais il est vrai que je vais pas non
plus il passé note en tant que ça si
j'arrive à jouer si j'ai plaisir à jouer
jojo que voilà mais j'ai passé deux
trois dernières années un peu compliqué
par rapport au jeu de golf
j'ai fait un genre de rejet moi je
reconnais volontiers un voilà est
aujourd'hui l'ajout recommencer un petit
peu à reprendre plaisir à jouer
c'est pas pour autant que je vais jouer
toutes les semaines n'ont pas non plus
imaginer quoi que ce soit merci beaucoup
rigolé alors parce que comme vous êtes
la directrice du musée condé là bas je
vous vous demander de nous faire
découvrir pas et plaisir un gardien très
bien vous faire la fête
[Musique]
le parcours de ce par 70 des personnes
domaine dans lequel il ya des chevreuils
il ya blue il ya des arbres magnifiques
c'est un des joyaux par des golfs des
yvelines et ça s'appelle tout simplement
le golfe
des zips ils craignent un spin off the
wall et annoncé la directrice que
greystar on est sur des départs du 3
actions ils sont pina chez des parents
oui ce sont des départs que nous avons
rénové entièrement pendant l'été
quelques mois voilà c'est parti des
travaux que nous venons réalisons tous
les ans les travaux de rénovation de
création alors ça peut toucher les
greens les bunkers lé nouveau départ et
c'est avec un certain sens monétique je
suis là depuis 9 ans on a les travaux
tous les tous les étés et là beaucoup de
chance d'avoir des propriétaires qui a
des styles beaucoup dans leur migration
du parcours et ses fans lui alors c'est
devenu un autre du parcours des chaînes
oui parce qu'il faut dire qu'il ya deux
parcours sur des usines
il ya 18 trous les chaînes wii industrie
illustre le teilleul tout à fait il date
de quand le parcours alors le parcours a
été ouvert en 1990 et bill baker à
l'architecte qui est à l'origine de ce
tracé et travaillons maintenant depuis
une dizaine d'années avec jean claude
cornier hop et architecte de golf et qui
nous fait toutes nos innovations voilà
ce sont des décisions qui sont prises
avec lui une collabo sauna et moi même
oui alors par exemple l'ordre des trous
a changé c'est que d'une époque oui
d'être n'était pas la même ready nations
et est actuellement le 10 à 30 ans il ya
une autre version
maintenant ça fait quand même près d'une
quinzaine vingtaine d'années que le
tracé maintenant et est officiel arrêté
voilà alors vous dites 1990 construction
de golf c'est un golf comme ok qui
accueille des greens kiwi a plutôt des
membres alors c'est un golf semi
commercial activités commerciales
importantes puisque on accueille
beaucoup de gens de passage encore une
fille et puis nous avons des membres
voilà donc des membres et je fais tout
mon possible pour que justement ses
membres se sentent comme dans un golf
associatif
voyez avec tous les avantages et
privilèges
et puis des prestations de qualité comme
nous leur offrons avec des parcours un
practice de restauration un accueil de
qualité de qualité il ya combien de
morts à peu près là on a à peu près à
380 points 185 membres
oui ce qui fait qu'on lui peuvent jouer
facilement quand il fait alors certes il
ya deux communautés alors comme les
greffiers de membres à la belle saison
il vaut mieux réserver
voilà on est bon ils ne sont pas
surchargées
ils peuvent toujours jouer quand ils le
souhaitent et ont d'ailleurs on leur
réserve des tranches horaires de
réservation le week-end principalement
la haute saison
je disais deux parcours 18 trous 9 trous
plus grande qualité à votre avis de
d'abord du 18 trous des chaînes alors
c'est un parcours technique
oui mais surtout très variés donc on
s'ennuie jamais on a une partie boisée
où nous trouvons actuellement de grands
grands nombreux chênes centenaires parce
que c'est une chaîne rai à la base et
puis vous avez une partie dans les
boisés sur 6 e trou et puis la partie de
là à la fin et plus sur la plaine mais
c'est pas pour autant que le parcours
est plus facile au contraire les gens
ont tous un petit peu à se laisser aller
en fin de parcours pensons que c'est
plus facile alors que ça ne l'est pas ça
parcours technique exigeant mais très
amusant père varié très variés et puis
et puis il ya ces sportifs quand même un
oui quelques quelques trous à la montée
on n'est pas non plus dans des golf
deux-montagnes 1 2 3
trop un peu vallonné mais globalement il
est mort ce n'est pas usant et fatiguant
certains ratés mais c'est très varié
d'un trou à l'autre on passe d'un trou
très protégé d'autres qui ont voix est
un peu plus aérien aéré c'est ce qu'ont
fait son charme on s'ennuie jamais ici
et non pas des désordres
maintenant j'ai vu aussi des chevreuils
à nos amis les ferrailles promesses qui
ça c'est vrai que le beau des yvelines
est aussi connu pour cette force d'avoir
sur notre propriété sur 95 ha on a une
quarantaine de chevreuil qui vivent en
totale liberté ici sont le golfe et et
ils sont tellement habitués à la
présence du golfeur qu'on peut tout à
fait d approcher à 3 4 5 m oui c'est ça
ils ont l'habitude quoi les habitudes
sont pas du tout apeuré on peut les
approcher et puis c'est vrai que ça fait
ça fait un quelque chose en plus qu'on
allait les gens quand ils parlent des
villes en dehors de nos prestations
ah oui c'est là où il ya les chevreuils
ont tout de suite tiendra une référence
à ces animaux et reste dans le domaine
il bouge pas sur le domaine est clos il
ya des murs fémur au triage donc ils
vivent sur le domaine
mais par contre c'est réguler on espère
que c'est un territoire de chasse
officiellement d'accord nous avons des
bracelets à part l'eau nf et nous
régulons quatre à cinq chevreuils par an
sachant qu'on a entre 8 et 12 des 112
naissances par an donc c'est normal
qu'il faille faire attention et de
répudier proprement le cheptel on est
d'accord de paris une quarantaine de
minutes 30 minutes porte d'auteuil en
2h35
voilà et on est quand même ailleurs on
essaie très dépaysant ce n'est pas les
paysans c'est on est on est à la fois
loin et pas long à dire qu'on a le
sentiment d'être vraiment la campagne
tout en restant dans des histoires très
abordable de paris il ya évidemment des
convictions oui
ouvert oui tous les jours j
qu'est-ce que vous souhaiter pour les
pour les années qui viennent ce qui
continue à tirer
oui le bon sens qui continue soit
vraiment reconnue pour pour ses
prestations mais ça je pense que depuis
maintenant quelques mois quelques années
on commence vraiment à parler de plus en
plus de nous il ya beaucoup de
reconnaissance de la part des instances
dirigeants puisque l'an prochain ne
recevons les championnats de france
dames en accord la coupe gaveau en juin
des mobiles
alors c'est sûr je suis assez sensible
et à terre dans les années peut-être
2020 recevoir une épreuve
professionnelle puisque c'est fait
partie de mes objectifs
éditions et nicolas boissonnat et
laurent sont très sensibles à moins ce
soir là et il faut surtout c'est ce que
nous faisons les rénovations les
améliorations c'est aussi pour être au
niveau du pied des charges prêt pour
recevoir un jour ce soir des preuves bah
il suffit de se promener de regarder on
voit que tout est là c'est d'abord un
dépaysement formidable et puis un
parcours combat mais il fut dominé c'est
un parcours qui est très exigeant et
quand nous avons notre vent pris tous
les ans et je suis fier des joueurs et
joueuses ont ni mal elle parcourt se
défend très bien et en plus vous savez
où vous habitez en plus de 20 avec les
chevreuils entre autres
[Musique]
[Rires]
oh
vous
[Musique]
bah c'est la troisième édition de l'open
tv 78 avec un nombre de participants
incroyable et ya plus de 100 ans
inscrits il ya des loups formidable a
gagné et ça a lieu cette année ou de
nouvelle de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
meilleur si vous voulez quelqu'un qui
sache en parler très très bien il ya un
accord y avait à coeur joie depuis c'est
laurent majorité le président de tv 78
il est par là bas rien l'événement
pourrait le trouver
c'est la troisième édition effectivement
de l'open tv 78 qui réunit les
passionnés de golf de toutes les
yvelines un grand nombre de sponsors
également qui nous suivent maintenant
pour cette troisième opus et qui cette
année a lieu pour la première fois au
golf de la base de loisirs de l'île de
loisir puisque tel est son nouveau nom
maintenant le golf blue green
notre volonté était de tourner sur
l'ensemble des golfs des idées et en
premier bien sûr france endemol de 50
euros
il fait beau c'est l'occasion aussi de
célébrer salle est un genre de l'été et
puis un collègue m'a convié en me disant
qu'il y avait une ambiance très
intéressante ici donc j'ai voulu
participer
j'aime beaucoup le bol il fait beau
effectivement et que c'est toujours
sympa de faire des complète en équipe
surtout avec avec mon meilleur ami quoi
on a un gars environs de 20 à 30% à
chaque open après on est limité par les
capacités du parcours bien entendu on
pourrait doubler les départs on n'a pas
voulu faire on a voulu maintenir sa
demande d'inscription de lord
effectivement d'une centaine c'est une
formule en scramble ce que l'on appelle
c'est à dire qu on joue à deux et
comprend la meilleure balle des deux du
coup c'est un esprit d'équipé un petit
peu comme la ryder cup ce qui permet
aussi d'avoir tous les niveaux qu'ils
puissent s'affronter dans une
compétition plutôt très fraternel et
très sympathique sans partenaire il n'y
a pas de n'y a pas de compétition
sportive
encore plus aujourd'hui où tout a un
coût il n'y a pas de l'eau les lots sont
importants et puis il faut montrer aussi
à travers ses partenaires que le golf
est accessible pour tous les milieux et
donc nous avons des partenaires de tous
les types nous les remercions tous en
premier lieu bien sûr le goff qui nous
accueillent mais tous les partenaires
qui nous accompagnent pour ce troisième
opus
je souhaite être partenaire d'un
événement sportif dans les yvelines et
l'open tv 78 donc compétition de golf à
une semaine de la ryder cup me
paraissait très pertinents je suis
artiste peintre et j'ai fait j'aime
peindre le mouvement et la couleur donc
j'essaie toupin collection sur le sport
dont le golf est à l'occasion de la
ryder cup j'ai fait pas mal de golfeurs
et du coup ça me semblait cohérent les
présenter lors de l'open
de télé soit 118 c'est la volonté de la
chaîne et du territoire et de l'ensemble
des partenaires de montrer que le golf
c'est avant tout un sport démocratique
accessible pour tous et qui n'est pas
réservé à une élite
il faut donc que les chaînes locales et
et v70 en premier lieu s'associe à des
opérations comme celle ci et montrent
que ce sport peut être pratiqué par tout
le monde
on est ici à 20 minutes de paris on est
ici à 20 minutes et où une heure de
l'ensemble de l'île de france et on peut
venir dans les yvelines premier première
terre de france en nombre de golf pour
pratiquer ce sport quel que soit son
niveau son milieu social et ses moyens
car c'est un peu un sport qui est
aujourd'hui très accessible c'est un
superbe challenge c'est important de
faire des événements sur le golf de
promouvoir le sport qui est le golfe
le gir et entre guillemets le vulgariser
un petit peu plus faire part de cette
activité parce qu'elle a encore un petit
peu méconnu aujourd'hui et donc c'est
bien d'en parler et de faire des
événements tels que les compétitions ou
des initiations pour essayer de drainer
un maximum de personnes vers cette
activité composants effectivement des
initiations propose des initiations
d'une part dans le cadre des initiations
bluegreen puisque nous on fait partie de
la chaîne du grime 49 golf en france
ici nous avons trois parcours on a deux
parcours 18 trous un parcours qui sera
un petit peu plus vallonné qui sera un
peu plus plat et tout sera un peu plus
long et un troisième qui est fait six
trous et qui est plus réservé je dirais
à y perdre à des personnes qui sont
néophytes ou débutantes et aussi lui
permettre de s'entraîner pour tout ce
qui est petit coucou d' approche etc
[Musique]
s'inquiète du virtuel pour révéler son
potentiel de golfeurs voilà ce que
promet lots birdie une application pour
mobiles présentés ici sur le parcours du
golf
isabella à plaisir le mode de
fonctionnement est simple dès la
première partie le joueur pourra
bénéficier de conseils pour optimiser
son plan de jeu pour des tarifs allant
de 499 à 100 euros par an donc là pour
le trou numéro un
on me dit de jouer le driver donc on ne
me frustre pas trop un fer 5
un gap wedge ensuite une approche punch
et 85 % de chances d'atteindre mon
objectif et ensuite je n'ai plus qu'à
remplir la carte en disant driver faire
singapour est du nombre de bots
et simplement ça me sert ça ne change
pas la routine habituelle 20 golfeurs
qui a l'habitude d'avoir une carte de
score et un crayon dans la poche
aucun appareil de mesure n'est
nécessaire mais l'application est en
mesure de calculer la difficulté d'un
coup en fonction des aptitudes du joueur
afin de déterminer quelles sont les
probabilités statistiques que vous
atteignez telle grille nous que vous
atteignez tel fairway ou que vous
puissiez
avoir le bonheur de réussir en dehors
dit sur tel ou tel trou l'ensemble des
téléphones devraient être prochainement
compatible et de nouvelles
fonctionnalités interdite en compétition
sont déjà en cours de développement
[Musique]
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
très vite pour un nouveau numéro 2 par
[Musique]